[Music]
olivia newton-john's daughter chloe
shares a touching tribute to her late
mom
giving fans a behind the scenes look at
their duet and it's sure to give you all
the feels
[Music]
the video shows chloe and olivia working
laughing and cuddling in the studio last
year a heartwarming sight to see as
earlier this week olivia died from her
long battle against breast cancer at 73
years old
[Music]
chloe sharing the visual was enough to
make us teary-eyed but the 36-year-old
singer also included a sweet message in
the caption quote it has been my honor
and continues to be my honor to be your
baby and best friend you are an angel on
earth and everyone touched by you has
been blessed she's
the most amazing person this the
integrity that she has blows me away as
an artist and as a person chloe's
previously opened up to e.t about her
unique relationship with her superstar
mom and following in her musical
footsteps she's taking it over
in et's last joint sit-down back in 2021
olivia was a proud mama and chloe shared
the best piece of advice she received as
an artist actually came from her mom
when i was making my album i was
listening to a lot of mariah and
christina aguilera and doing all the
riffs and everything and she said you
know it's so much more important chloe
that you
come from your heart and you make people
feel something and you can have an
imperfect note but as a singer it's much
more important that people feel you
than you showing off vocal tricks i
think that was one of the most the like
one of the most profound pieces of
advice
um as an artist that i got from her
chloe's created her own lane but seems
like olivia's lessons still resonate
today she ended her tribute writing i
love you forever my life giver my
teacher my mama we're very very
different i'm a very different kind of
artist and i like that
[Music]
you